hey so what is the best sunglasses for
men in 2018 I am Daniel Moritz and this
is d LM model lifestyle
[Music]
so what is the best sunglasses for men
in 2018 well there's a lot of sunglasses
are there a lot of shapes a lot of sizes
a lot of brands right but the most
important thing when it comes to
sunglasses is the shape of the glasses
why is that so important
well it's really bad if you wear very
expensive sunglasses but they don't fit
with your face shape so how do you know
what kind of glasses will fit in with
your face shape well it's pretty easy
the general rule is you have to wear the
opposite of your face shape for example
if you have a round face you have to
wear glasses that has a square or
rectangular shape now if you have a
square or rectangular face shape wear
round glasses and if you see somebody
with cool glasses you think to yourself
wow those are cool glasses why because
of the shape not because you know the
brand so the most important thing when
it comes to sunglasses is the shape of
the glasses so now you know what kind of
shape you need to buy they will fit in
with your face shape right but there are
sunglasses out there that has a shape
that will fit in with almost every kind
of face shape on this planet they're not
round they're not square hybrid they are
the aviator sunglasses
these guys are Microsoft pick for 2018
they look sporty
they look classy they're super cool and
they will fit in with most of your
styles that you would want to wear so
for 2019 these are the guys you need to
get now if you need a new pair of
sunglasses
I would suggest Ray Bans aviator
sunglasses a lot of link in the
description so you can check them out I
wasn't sponsored to do this video for
Ray Ban but they are super cool thank
you for watching please subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]